is there something that stands out to
you
i mean i'm joking about like best
something that was impactful to you just
to put it out there i don't think
there's any
any way to say that they're objectively
you know the best fee documentaries all
the time but for me and you may find
this interesting given your background
is that
i think
my top three are all
from
the eastern bloc actually so
so aquarella
by kosokovsky victor kosovki is one of
my favorite and it's a couple years old
now
which is sort of a meditation on the
place water has on our planet and in our
lives
um
i i think uh a woman captured that i
mentioned which was shot in hungary
there's a feature-length one
both both are feature links yeah um it
is just brilliant and it i think has yet
to find distribution here
you know but it's the perfect example of
what they call you know verite
or direct um
non-fiction filmmaking a european woman
this is the synopsis the european woman
has been kept by family as a domestic
slave for 10 years
drawing courage from the filmmaker's
presence
she decides to escape the unbearable
oppression
and become a free person wow
so the filmmaker
is part of the story part of the story
becomes it didn't start that way but
during the course of the story the
filmmaker under becomes comes to
understand that this is actually
modern-day slavery and rather than just
allow it to be
actually enables and assists this woman
to to free yourself from slavery and
become a free woman i wonder sorry on a
small tangent before we get to number
three like icarus is interesting too
how often
do you become part of the story or the
story is different
because of your presence
but like uh like you
you changed the tide of history yeah
well back to like one person at a time
that we keep talking you know we keep
coming back to that theme on some level
so so this could tie in interesting to
one of my one of my favorite films
actually so
um
the last two films that i would mention
from my top four list would be the third
eastern block one would be a film called
immortal in 2019 which was shot in
russia by a russian woman
that sort of you know examines
the place of the state
in um
in shaping individuals to be vehicles
for the state i mean that's my own
synopsis but that's one of my takeaways
from the brilliant 60-minute dock or so
um again russian filmmaking right it's
really quite
quite good and powerful
the fourth one would be a frederick
wiseman film titica follies
um which was filmed in the u.s decades
ago
inside basically the bowels of a insane
asylum or a mental health institution
and and i bring up wiseman because you
know he is really
the the godfather so to speak of of
direct cinema or cinema verite
you